my best of seven that went the distance
and uh
I know that the TD Garden is emptying
out and there's a lot of disappointment
for the home team here but we are here
to congratulate the Eastern Conference
champions so we do have two pieces of
hardware and they're named for Boston
Celtic Legends and the irony is not lost
on me believe me Bob Cousy trophy for
the champions of the Eastern Conference
first and then the Larry Bird trophy to
the MVP of the Eastern Conference Finals
and I think you all recognize the man
who was going to do the honors this is
Alonzo Morning
this is the yeah
that's a proud moment for our franchise
it gives me great pleasure to present
the 2023 Eastern Conference championship
trophy to your Miami Heat that's the Bob
cousey trophy to the Heat
[Applause]
bam you've got this in your hands I'm
going to ask you the questions this
everybody was
there everybody was wondering when you
take a gut punch like it you could took
in in game six how you would come back
how you would respond and what was the
thought process going into game seven
here
man just a win uh everybody rallied
around each other you know spoke got us
in and made us uh watch a inspirational
video for 15 minutes and I guess it
fooled us what was the inspirational
video oh man just stand together you
know the ship get Rocky just stay
together and keep believing in one
another
um spoil you right here you have to
answer that question what's the
inspirational video you showed your team
no it wasn't about the video it's just
about an incredible group of men right
here we are the men in the arena
with our dust sweat and blood on our
faces uh and I think a lot of people can
relate to this team
because uh you know sometimes you have
to suffer you know for the things that
you really want uh and this group has
shown fortitude uh when there are
inevitable letdowns and failures but uh
to have that perseverance to pick
yourself up have that Collective Spirit
to keep on forging ahead until uh until
you get to accomplish what you want to
um we still have more to do but uh you
know we do want to tip our hats to the
Boston Celtics and their organization
they are first class and
they made us get better they made us get
better last year was extremely painful
we thought about it all all season long
and if you don't have an opponent like
that to bring it to a different level
sometimes you don't get there so
congratulations going to the finals nice
going